投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀。現在是臺北時間2026年8月20號禮拜四,早上8點31分。大家早安,我是頂浩。
每天早上開拍前半小時,我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經、新聞時事變化。
美國股市是三大指數小幅收高,非半賣壓還是很沉重,但至少已經終止了連續三個交易日的顯著跌勢。
主要原因就來自於貝森特護盤了。
這一次美國財政部在昨天晚上
宣佈大幅加碼回購長天期公債
也帶動了債券價格的反彈
殖利率明顯的回落
稍微緩解高殖利率
對於股票市場估值所形成的壓力
不過目前所宣佈的流動性支撐規模
如果持續提升下去
那是不是等同於累QE呢
另外一方面
那如果只是短期內穩定市場流動性
讓債券市場不要一路的恐慌
那麼這一套措施
它能夠維持多久呢
它能夠形成的效果
可能會類似於過去的
美日聯合匯率聲明嗎
所以今天就來跟投資朋友觀察
這一波如果能夠讓美債市場
能夠稍微持穩
是不是代表著股市的估值
能夠重新的放大
事實上這一次宣佈是蠻意外的
沒有人想到
因為就算公債資利率的創高
市場上也沒有引起崩潰性的跌幅
所以反而是有點提前
釋出動作的意味
因為照理來講
國票市場從高點跌下來就跌一天而已
貝森特就直接進場了
這一次是至少把10年到30年期公債的流動性支持回購規模來加倍
那消息公佈之後
30年期的美債殖利率是一度下跌了10個基點
來到5.185%
從07年以來的最高點來開始回落
那新一輪的操作它是9月9號才會啟動
所以等同於貝森特是在做前瞻指引
告訴你我即將要採取行動了
原定9月到11月初
最多要回購140億美元的長債
現在至少增加140億
所以可以看得出來
前一次是針對整個2046年到2056年
到期債券20億美元的回購
現在出現了10倍以上的超額認購
這等同於貝森特正在用財政部版本的扭轉操作
來壓低長端的利率
讓你長端利率上行速度不要太快
以短期國庫券先籌資
然後買回流動性比較差的一些舊常債
來改善交易環境
沒人買你沒關係
反正我財政部會買你哦
也向市場傳遞出
政府不願意放任殖利率失控上升的訊號
讓大家意識到
你們不能夠期待
長天期國債殖利率就這樣一路上去
因為你會有一個最終買家
就是我們
等到失控的時候
我們就會進場了
當然了
大家都知道
這也只能舒緩技術面和情緒面
它沒辦法解決現在常債賣壓的根源嘛
現在長債的根源
一方面是我們過去所提到的
因為這些投資等級債
這些巨頭都在瘋狂發債
那一個是發7%到8%
一個是發4%到5%
那兩家公司
一個是微軟Google
他們也不太可能倒
美國政府也不太可能倒
那有時候
這些投資等級債的發行
直接把長債的供給
直接給吞噬掉了
最終買盤可能會集中在投資等級債
所以壓抑住目前
常債的價格
這是一種角度
那另外一方面
常債利率的創高
仍然要看通膨是否能夠受控
還有美國的經濟是否會降溫
財政部的做法
本質上其實就是
用更多的短債發行
去回收部分常債
替長端市場來
填補它的流動性
所以它當然短期內
它可以壓低殖利率
它可以穩住市場情緒
但赤字融資的問題消失了嗎
通膨預期的問題消失了嗎
其實都沒有
所以除非他就這樣子一直互判
要不然其實短期內
是無法解決這個問題的
其實現在經濟學家
針對美國的經濟數據
還是兩個極端
如果有AI
那的確美國經濟現在數學表現還不錯
可是如果看實體消費
其實已經算是蠻疲憊的
就業市場已經好幾個月軟化了
所以照理來說
聯準會是沒有太多升息的理由
但是債券市場面對的
可能並不是單純貨幣政策的問題
它就是供給的問題
這一次長天極國債
不只是美國嘛
全世界都在創高啊
第一個就是發債量實在太恐怖了
如果我們細節觀察
今年AI相關的債務供給是4890億
去年也不過3000億啊
一整年啊
現在是到現在就已經4890億了
美元投資等級帶的發行規模
已經超過1.5兆了
這個數據上升的速度實在太快
所以我們才講說現在的風險呢
都不是什麼經濟太熱了
AI太好了
所以聯總會要升息啊
而是可能內需經濟
已經沒有這麼好了
就業市場已經開始軟化了
可是長端殖利率還是壓不下來
這是最大的一個問題
那當然我們知道常債失控
壓力也很大
聯總會可能
如果常債利率已經失控
告訴你說
30年期公債殖利率5.5了
快要6%了
那聯總會可能真的就要被迫在
明顯很疲軟的經濟數據下要升息
那對於美國而言
那就是經濟上的災難
經濟都已經這麼差了
你還要升息
所以現在我們只能說
美國目前超過一半的財政赤字
還在透過短期國庫券來做融資
他只是把問題給往後延
他也不是發行中長期國債
我們看短債現在佔赤字融資的比重
大概已經突破了50%
而且持續在上升
同時常在佔比下降的時候
市場等同於獲得一股
有點類量化寬鬆
它不是直接性的量化寬鬆
不過等同於放錢了
歷史上曾經出現過四次的類似情況
標普500指數在後續三個月
六個月和12個月的報酬
幾乎都是長期平均的兩倍
所以樣本數雖然不是很多
不過方向很明確
就財政部要做多了
財政部不允許現在流動性收縮
財政部不允許現在市場上
有缺錢的情況
財政部正在對賭AI的成功
來幫助現在市場上
本來已經稀缺的流動性
太多人要借錢發展AI了
錢不太夠了
甚至影響到我們美國國債
長期的買盤
所以我來幫助你一把
有這樣的感覺
那當然就是來自於短期國庫券
期限短
價格波動低
主要在貨幣市場
銀行準備已經看赴買回市場當中來做流動
它通常以前不太會直接排擠股票資金
但是因為這幾年常在發行增額
也在慢慢的增加
然後也容易推高長期的利率
壓低股票的估值
所以現在就藉由這樣的一個方式
舒緩一下市場的情緒
當然最後的問題就是
風險會不會消失呢
風險當然不會消失
現在美國政府就是
就是一直刷卡
一直刷信用卡刷刷刷刷
那因為房貸還不出來了
信貸還不出來了
質押還不出來了
一直刷卡一直刷卡
大概就是這樣的
你說那這樣子肯定有問題
不一定
它現在有很多卡可以刷
有的還有利率還有回扣
所以還可以撐一陣子
大概就這樣子
所以風險並沒有完全消失
就是再次風險搬家而已
財政不透過發行短債買回常債
然後表面上瓦解了常債公債
流動性枯竭和殖利率飆升的問題
可是轉嫁的風險就是政府自身的短天期的再融資
還有利率波動的風險
它並沒有削減財政赤字的問題
通膨僵固的問題也沒解決
地緣增值也沒解決
所以只能夠解決短期的情況
不過至少了解財政部的態度
不讓你跌有這樣的感覺
有點類似以前的鐵達尼號不是沉默之後
然後全世界就痛定思痛
說最大的改革就是以後大型的郵輪
一定要有足夠的救生艇
聽起來百分之百正確
但是最有意思的地方就在這邊
我之前看了一本書
講美國安全史
他講是1915年
芝加哥號
就是美國的另外一個郵輪
準備要出航的時候
船身突然撤翻
800多人死亡
不少人就死在離岸很近的地方
後來調查發現
因為鐵達尼號那個時候沉沒了
鐵達尼號沉沒以後
大家就說一定要裝很多救生艇
然後裝太多
然後設計沒有好之後
嘴果還沒開出去就已經先倒了
我不是說救生艇害死人
是說任何降低一種風險的規則
他只是把風險搬到另外一邊而已
金融監管也是如此
你把銀行的風險壓下去
資金搞不好跑到私人信貸
你更看不到到底風險有多大了
你把交易所管嚴
槓桿可能會跑到場外
那現在就是面臨一樣的一個處境
當然很多人說
美國政府既然缺錢
又還在繼續發債
為什麼還要花錢
已經把發出去的廠債買回來呢
美國政府到現在
不是還是全世界最安全
最容易交易的資產嗎
我們一直講的美元霸權
大家一直說都沒有消失
為什麼現在要這樣做呢
這是兩回事
大家要區別
信用安全跟市場流動性是兩回事
現在的風險主要集中在流動性這一塊
美國政府不太可能還不出美元債的
這是信用問題
但是現在赤字過大
AI巨頭又借錢
然後海外買盤又變弱的時候
那流動性不好
所以我才要介入
所以它是兩個問題
這有點邏輯悖論
你要了解說
有時候我們會把不同層次的問題問在一起
美國政府為什麼要回購自己的債
難道美債不安全
美債是安全的
但是有流動性問題
AI這麼賺錢
為什麼科技巨頭還要到全球借錢
難道自己沒現金嗎
有現金也不代表要全部自掏腰包
資產配置跟融資成本才是關鍵
打官司為什麼要請律師呢
難道法官分不清對錯嗎
這邏輯悖論
邏輯一輩子要了解
好那這是第一點
這是財政部給予的態度
它其實不像是真實操作
它更像是一種前瞻指引
華許不做前瞻指引
我背身特做
告訴你們
不要對賭美國國債崩盤
不要讓美國國債一直跌
好那第二個觀察重點
來自於通膨的僵固性
因為昨天我們有提到
美國的汽油價格
尤其在柴油的部分
每價人已經高達5美元了
大家不理解那是什麼概念
我們如果把它換算成期貨價格
歐洲的柴油價格
最近正在瘋狂飆升
每桶已經接近到170了
這幾乎是布蘭特原油的兩倍
美國汽油價格年漲幅30
柴油已經漲了46%了
造成這種背離的原因
就是現在有接近一億桶的原油
仍然滯留在荷姆茲海峽
加上中國的煉油量開始降低
讓原油賬面上看起來沒那麼緊
但是柴油和汽油
可直接的消費產品供應
反而來得更加吃緊
那剛才講到
這種通膨所形成的外溢僵固性
你說只是漲一個月
然後兩個月之後跌回來
那就裝作什麼事都沒發生
單一事件
可是它已經盤了大半年
都在這麼高的位階
一定會有一點外溢效果
舉一個比較直觀的
我們知道昨天七夕
情人節通常有些人需要一些開銷
比如紅酒 飯店 酒吧 喝酒
經濟學就做了一個統計
把晚餐 把電影 把計程車費加總以後
全世界現在情人節的約會成本
正在瘋狂上升
這種僵固性就一路外溢出去
其中最高的是上海
上海每過一次情人節
大概要655美元
那差不多要1.8萬
紐約聖彼得堡
聖湖安緊追起後
臺北大概在前10名左右
北京大概第12
真正拉開的是什麼
是兩人份的兩道餐的晚餐
什麼意思
就是最貴的就是在當天你要吃飯
每年的情人節當然價格就貴一點
可是每年情人節的征服又越來越快了
這件事情都意味著
全球這種通膨的僵固性
萬一出去以後
餐廳價格會下滑嗎
菜單成本會下滑嗎
不會
所以這是很重要的一件事情
加上川普針對整個中東局勢的喊話
現在看起來很明顯
進入到持續性的僵持了
幾個小時之前川普在發文
他說沒有人比我更懂伊朗
伊朗他們想要更多的機會
想要讓他們有更多的機會
能夠達成協議
但是很可悲的事情是
他們並沒有好好的把握
所以今天我宣佈
針對伊朗發動史上
對任何國家最為沉重
最為嚴厲的經濟打擊
他宣佈要經濟打擊
這是一場前所未見的
最大規模的經濟戰
我們要全面的孤立伊朗
他們的海軍沒了
空軍遭到摧毀
軍事工廠剩下一片的廢墟
貨幣一文不值
整個國家搖搖欲墜
所以我要宣佈採取史上最沉痛的經濟打擊
任何國家只要記得金融機構企業機場
跟伊朗做任何生意都會面臨非常嚴重的後果
不管是石油走失貨幣互換
現金轉移地下匯兌
全部都必須要馬上停止
他稱之為今天為經濟版的D-Day
所有的盟友都必須跟美國站在一塊
這是川普在兩個小時之前的發文
最嚴厲的經濟打擊
那其實概念就是
不會有軍事戰了
最嚴厲的經濟戰
那就是代表不會有軍事戰
那就說明了
整件事情僵局可能會拉得更久
那伊朗的回應也很快出現
伊朗直接表態
革命衛隊表示說
一旦美國如果再次擴大攻勢
會把報復的範圍
從中東延伸到歐洲
那目前最新的發表是
包括塞浦勒斯
包括南歐等國家的美軍設施
只要配合美軍發動空襲
伊朗會採取無限制的報復
你永遠不知道什麼時候會射出無人機
你也永遠不知道什麼時候會到達你的基地
伊朗過去就曾經攻擊4000公里以外的
不管是意大利或者希臘相關基地
土耳其也曾經攔截過伊朗的彈道飛彈
那大部分都沒有造成具體傷害
不過伊朗的態度很明確
你們敢跟美國來報復我
那我也報復你們
大概就這樣的一個情況
所以必須承認
美方過去的確有一次次的
嘗試的遞出橄欖枝給期限
那伊朗現在也撕破臉了
現在大家都不願意讓步
那國際關係跟感情一樣
每天就熱臉貼冷屁股
最後通常不是感動對方
就自己用的籌碼就越來越少了
那現在溝通沒有回應
下一步往往就從示好變成施壓
那最後通膨問題就沒辦法解決了
所以有時候
美國其實過去幾周
你已經看得出來稍微軟化了
對於什麼核設施問題
其實都已經沒有那麼僵局
只求目前能夠儘可能
在其中選舉之前
把通膨問題 把食油問題 把醞釀問題稍微解決
不過伊朗看起來 敬酒不吃 吃罰酒
感覺也不是很願意做回應
所以就熱點貼冷屁股
川普現在也不想管了 對不對
男的說 昨天七夕 我送的巧克力好吃嗎
女的說 很好吃 我男朋友都很喜歡
所以川普這幾天 對伊朗就有這種感覺
每天熱點貼冷屁股
一邊留裁判窗口 一邊強調給時間
結果發了幾次文之後不回應
現在要出史上最高強度的經濟戰了
好那這是第二層問題
通膨的僵固性
好那第三層問題
當然始作俑者是誰
這一波怎麼上升這麼快
每一戰是已經打那麼久
大家都快無感了
重點其實還是來自於AI的借債需求實在太強了
美國現在這些科技巨頭已經不滿足於美元債市了
開始大量的跑到加拿大
瑞士英國等市場來借錢
Google今年在加拿大
發行了85億加幣的債券
一度創下當地時尚最大規模
亞馬遜過兩週
也跑到加拿大
也發行了140億加幣的投資整齊債
那兩家公司最近
也開始跑到瑞士法郎來發債
那阿發貝目前也在英國
在上禮拜也發了100年期的英鎊債
100年期
美國政府買100年期都不一定有人買
他還會發行100年期
那問題是這些市場都遠小於美國
巨頭一進場就好像大象
走進整個小房間
然後把所有市場的錢
把英國的錢洗劫一空
加拿大的錢洗劫一空
所以這很神奇
加拿大最高品質的
AAA級公司債的利差
近期甚至一度高於
信用評級較低的A級債券
那說明科技巨頭搶錢搶風了
隨便給你開資利率
反正就先給我錢再說
所以這就是集中度風險
就是大量的資金
和投資等級債的供給
全面集中在這些科技巨頭身上
那等同於全球正式進入一場
高強度的資本市場軍備競賽
直接把國債市場也給拉下海了
那好在現在貝森特
自己買自己的國債
那你們如果堅持要買投資等級債
那國債我就自己發行
然後再自己買回來吧
看起來是這樣子
當然另外一方面
用量越來越大
也代表著我們一定會讓AI生活進步
會不會產生更多的浪費
這就是市場上最大擔憂
也許AI投資最後能夠成
那這些投資最後就能夠創造更多的生產力
那現在市場上之所以擔心是什麼
一方面是擔心排擠到國債的買盤
造成債券市場的壓力
那第二點擔心的是內生性的擔心
就是你今天那麼多錢
那如果很多人去使用AI
沒有造成生產力提升
因為很多人使用AI是浪費了
我舉一個比較直觀的
就跟影印機一樣
影印機是什麼樣
以前的影印文件是一件大事
那個機器很貴
速度又很慢
所以大家印之前就會想
這是需要印嗎
但是影音機後來越來越便宜了
越來越快之後
辦公室就不會因此變得更繩子
反而出現那種順便一份
每個人都印一份
先印出來再說
就一件事情編輯成本經濟零
用AI越來越方便之後
通常人類不是更有效率的使用AI
是把使用量開爆
亂生成圖
做一些有的沒的AI影片
對於這個世界毫無幫助
產值毫無提升
你也不是要給別人看
你就是做好玩的
最後就一直消耗電力
一直消耗算力
一直消耗GPU
一次生成幾篇小說文章
幾毛錢而已
當寫程式
做圖片
拍影片
分析資料
都便宜到不行的時候
辦公室用值就越來越多了
那最後被拖垮的是什麼
大家擔心
有一部分人一直都擔心
如果你也沒有造成
實質生產力提升
只是每天大家都一直生產
吉普利圖片
那不就是一種效率浪費嗎
那不是一種泡沫嗎
這就是市場上的擔憂
第三層
那最後的擔憂是什麼
當然就是
你發這麼高的債
你要怎麼還得起這麼高的利息呢
你不能
如果現在低利率時代
零利率
那隨便發嘛
這完全可以理解
利率這麼高
你還借這麼多錢
事實上我們看
美國聯邦政府的淨利息支出
佔GDP比值
其實也在快速的升高
從2020年前後
大概是1.4%
一路提升到3.2%
那翻了一整倍
畢竟歷史新高
那原因當然不只是
美國的國債越滾越大
是過去幾年高利率
讓到期的債券
它必須用更高的成本發行
以前都是發行1%2%的利率
國債
還以前就很輕鬆
可是我沒錢
那我就必須要發薪再還就債
可是以前發債成本就1%到2%
現在要4%到5%
那過10年我不是壓力更大了嗎
所以你就觀察到
淨利息佔GDP比例的速度越來越高
當利息支出增加比經濟成長還要來得快的時候
壓力就很大了
一方面是美國的國債的利息支出
已經超越一整年的國防支出
這是一個很大的壓力
代表國防社福基建減稅上的錢
它就會被擠壓掉
那就變成你每年賺了這麼多錢
你發現都拿去繳利息了
也不是說美國明天就還不起錢
但債務越高
殖利率又越高
你又在利率保持這麼高的水準
又大量的去發債
未來就必須要靠更高的稅收
更高的赤字
然後通膨或者金融壓抑
來嘗試的做消化
所以換句話說
市場上最後一層對賭是什麼
就是不只是美國國債
發行成本很高
你以後要還我們很多錢
以後投資等級在科技巨頭也是
那你真的可以賺得了
這麼多錢給我們嗎
殖利率7% 8%
越來越高
再降的一個效果
所以這個時候市場上壓力就很大
變成了償還問題
跟那個酒店小姐有點像
酒店小姐就這樣
好賭的爸
生病的媽
上學的弟弟
和破碎的他
以前電影常演
那女主角下午去進修部上課
晚上去做酒店小姐
半夜還要照顧自己的弟弟
凌晨又去加油站
早上還去送外賣
中午還去超商打工
辛苦賺到的錢
只能還爸爸的債
好不容易辛苦賺了一整個月
只夠付利息
連本金都不夠還
人生絕望你知道嗎
所以現在大家擔心就是
如果AI沒有那種史詩級的爆發
你發這麼高的利息
經濟成長
到時候每年大家賺的錢
只能夠拿來付利息
難道不是一種市場的泡沫嗎
這就是市場的擔憂
的確有其道理
講起來好感傷
待會去救助一下嗜血少女好了
好感傷
但不管怎麼說
某種程度而言
等同於有幾個方向可以解決
第一降低利率
把利率融資成本大幅的壓低
就解決這個問題了
但是前提是什麼
吾爾戰士
美伊衝突要解決
衝突的僵固性不能夠存在
這也是川普目前改裁經濟戰的原因
另外一方面
當然很簡單生產力的爆發
直接讓科技巨頭告訴你
以後你的錢每年翻倍翻倍的賺
以後每年通膨都10%
那有什麼害怕的呢
反正我的資產每年都翻倍
這另外一種角度
所以這其實某種程度就意味著
金融壓抑會成為未來幾年市場的主流
什麼叫做金融壓抑
叫Financial Repression
就是政府透過壓低利率
維持較高的通膨率
讓實質利率長期恢復
以降低龐大的債券負擔
那當然現在問題就是
像實質利率為正
我們舉例來說
如果現在通膨是9%
那利率是4%
那等同於每年
大概就有5%的購買力
應該講說
你有5%的購買力被消失了
因為你存錢
你只能拿到4塊錢
但是通膨已經9塊了
所以等於每年
大概有5%左右的購買力
從存款人和債券持有人當中
移到政府手上了
那INF就指出
說以前最常使用的
金融壓抑的做法
就是包括限制資本流動
要求銀行或者退休金
持有政府公債
我賣你很多公債
大家每個人退休金都有公債
退休金都持有
主權債都持有
這樣子以後通膨
只要高於我的殖利率
問題就解決了
但現在通膨
要明顯的高於長天級公債
也有難度
所以現在問題就來自於
美國未來要採取金融壓抑
他就要很多種政策引導
來流向公債市場
要求大家每個人都買
然後過了兩年發現
我買的產品完全跑不贏通膨
這是最理想的一個做法
那債務問題就稍微解決了
要解決債務問題
其實唯一方式
我看過去100年200年的歷史
只有一種方式
高通膨
債務很大
我現在欠大家2000萬
那感覺是很大一筆數目
過50年以後
2000萬可能跟現在200萬差不多
因為貨幣會貶值
就跟以前
那800萬買一套房已經算貴了
現在800萬
兩房都不一定買得起
所以用這樣的一個效果
通膨讓購買力沖銷
那苦的是中產
但是是解決這場金融問題
最好的這種淡化的方式
OK
這也給投資朋友做一些思考
那我們看美國股市
四大指數表現來做一些追蹤
道瓊指數上漲119.0.22%
收在53,463點
標普上漲16.0.21%
收在7,707點
納指上漲41.0.16%
收在26,331點
倍半則是下跌254.2.12%
是在11738點
那當然我們知道三大指數目前還在高位震盪
那晶片股其實也開始做橫盤整理了
現在市場上更為關注的是
錢到底有多稀缺
其實巨頭們目前看起來還是蠻有信心的
因為AI的確正在推高企業的籌資需求
可是今年第二季
美國透過IPO增資或者科展債或者SPV
合計募資的金額2520億
它的確比去年同期高了不少
可是問題在於
他們的回購力量
其實也沒有想象中來得低
如果我們細節觀察
現在很多投資人
反而在二季度到三季度
尤其現在財報季過後
解禁期之後
整體回購金額反而看起來更大了
這就說明著
即便他已經投那麼多錢到AI了
他們還是願意繼續回購
然後來技巧性的抬升市場股價
比如說以SK海力士為例
SK海力士最近是宣佈
40兆韓元290億美元的
庫藏股的實施計劃
從8月20號到11月19號
會回購最多2400萬股
並且註銷
這規模堪稱罕見
應該是史上最大
這也說明著
公司反正現在不管這麼多
你不要覺得我好像擴敞
自由現金流就很虛
我自由現金流比科技巨頭好得多
賺了這麼多錢
直接股票回購
直接技巧性的來回饋股東
把你的股價應試給抬高
所以這一波回購
他就不只是在護盤
他也是在安撫韓國散戶
我猜李在明政府搞不好有參與其中
說服SK海力士立即進行回購
不要讓股價再跌了
這一波你說韓國股市
還是今年表現最為亮麗的市場
你覺得韓國散戶韓國股民
會特別感謝李在明嗎
這就是問題了
他的總體績效年初到現在
仍然是全球表現最亮麗的
漲幅又接近五成
可是洗過一輪以後
波動性會害李在明的民調受損
這是非常明顯的跡象
所以大家開始出招了
臺廠的部分
這一波槓桿沒有上得特別大
而且重點是獲利也在暴升
臺汽在今年的獲利率
要成長到五成
去年年底預估
今年也不過成長18%
現在已經接近到五成了
速度越來越快
所以必須承認
現在這種市況
我們其實只看到
還是來自於利率的沉壓
對於股票市場估值所產生的壓力
便宜的股票現在定義也在改變
你像美國的股息殖利率
已經來到4%到7%了
甚至高於政府公債的殖利率
那投資人買股票除了資本利得
本身就能夠拿到相對具有吸引力的現金收益
那現在情況又稍微相反了
美股股息殖利率剩下1%了
但是美國長期公債殖利率都已經拉昇到5%到6%了
兩者差距已經來到數十年的罕見水準
這代表的是
就現在市場上
已經有一段時間
願意持有高估值的股票
那市場壓住的絕對不是股息
都是企業的高速獲利成長
那麼如果殖利率高到一定程度以後
你就會把那些想要股息的人
重新吸引回來
兩邊就在持續性的進行角力
當然不代表說
你要股息還是要更多的資本利得
我們還是要了解自己的初衷
就是說如果你是價值投資
重點從來都不是
股價有沒有回到你的成本
而是公司的基本面
是否符合原先的預期
從營收到獲利
到自由現金流
互成合
管理資本的配置有沒有變差
你要了解你當時的
一直講成中
不是不是不是
是初中
你要了解自己的初中
你是看價值投資
那你就只關注基本面
你不要管股價
到位了就買
做股息投資
重點就是配息能否穩定成長
配發率是否健康
你不能說
比如說殖利率突然變高或者變低
就大幅影響到
不能說股價漲貨鐵就大幅影響到你的投資
股息投資那就是它的配息吸不吸引你
它的殖利率吸不吸引你
你做緊急循環投資
重要的就是供需循環
價格 資本指數的高低
你做科技投資
你當然就是這項技術
你認為它有沒有改變原本當時的方向
它的市佔率或成合是否有持續的領先
每一種策略都有自己的判斷詞
最危險的就是你表面上都說長期投資
現在利率預期稍微一動
你就說那我稍微先避開
不是這樣子玩的
一定要了解自己原本的初心
前兩天我才看了一個談話節目
那裡面的主持人
問那個男生一個問題
不許撒謊
講說你要如實回答
如果有一天
你曾經最愛的那個女人
女孩子嫁給了別人
可是婚後過得並不好
然後又離婚了
然後帶著一身傷痕回來找你
那你心裡還會愛她嗎
你會毫不猶豫地娶她嗎
那不要裝大度
那我就看他們在討論
後來有一個回答
我覺得特別好
他講說
當你有了一個後
你還是選了第二個
之後又回來找第一個
那並不是他回心轉意了
是第二個放棄他了
你知道嗎
就在他心裡
第二個永遠比第一個
這個還要排名後面
所以你也不用考慮
就放棄他吧
除非是李多輝
不是
所以你可以觀察到
投資最怕的
他不是看錯
是一黨曾經拋棄你的股票
誤當成終就會回頭愛你的機會
很多人買在高點被套
股價一路下跌
反彈一下
大家回來找我了
然後立刻加碼攤品
卻沒有看清楚
他的回來
那是基本面回來了嗎
是市場情緒的問題嗎
是資金輪動的問題嗎
是跌身反彈而已嗎
你以為自己在等解套
你以為你在等一段
其實早已變質的關係
能夠恢復原樣
其實不可能的
真正成熟的投資
不是因為自己曾經愛過
持有過
賠過
不是一定要完全經歷過
然後就非得把它買回來
而是重新問過自己
現在的獲利估值
產業的位置競爭力
還值得我持有嗎
我認為問這個問題
比問一個利率估值的變化
而決定你要不要
持續停留在市場當中
有著極大差別
你要了解自己的初心
外在環境永遠都在改變
我們聊的這個利率問題
難道是這兩天才聊的嗎
我已經聊了兩週了
他都不反應
現在找了一個理由來反映
那我覺得很清楚
它仍然是使得股市
有中期回調的理由
而並不是泡沫破滅的風險
好 臺股反彈423點
45105點了
本場事件唯一的重點只有一個
不是說美國債務問題就解決了
不是說美國債務問題會直接爆掉
是財政部在它的任期底下
貝森特不允許在自己手上爆掉
這是貝森特在本次操作當中
最為明顯的訊號
也給投資朋友做一些思考
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上半點半
早晨財經速解讀
再相見
祝各位投資朋友看板順利
財管愉快